las autoridades rusas han dicho que
permitirán la evacuación de los civiles
que se encuentran en la planta química
de azote en la disputada ciudad de
severodonezk e también han exigido la
rendición de los soldados ucranianos que
según han dicho se encuentran escondidos
la situación recuerda lo ocurrido en
otra ciudad ucraniana mariupol a donde
por semanas soldados y civiles
estuvieron atrapados hasta la rendición
completa y total de los ucranianos y la
toma del control de la ciudad por parte
de las tropas de moscú que el conflicto
en el este de ucrania se está
enquistando también lo refleja la
decisión de moscú de
endurecer las penas para aquellos
soldados que deciden cambiarse de bando
mientras que un tribunal ucraniano ha
decidido ratificar la suspensión de las
actividades de otro partido político
acusándolo de prorruso se trata del
cuarto partido político que es
sancionado con una medida similar desde
el comienzo de esta fase de la guerra
entre rusia y ucrania en febrero